This equation is from a book.
from Shadow aggarwal a very
popular author of all kinds of machine learning
books
And he's very well written I would strongly recommend
any of his books. He has a book on.
Machine learning for text. I recommend it. He has a book on data mining
I recommend it is a book on using
machine learning or data money for healthcare. I recommend
that too. In fact, I recommend all of his books, but here
let's just pay attention to this the formula.
We want to understand the formula here.
We can see we have w.
Now this author I guess does not use the Bold.
Convention, I would prefer that they did.
But that's the Matrix the transpose of the Matrix multiplied by
the scale value, which here is the mean?
of the data
this five function is the activation function what I
try to really say, is that a neural network?
Is linear algebra?
So what we're going to do is look at we will look at the mathematical representation
of it.
And look at it in its python
implementation.
but we'll start with the python implementation first because that's
we want to get the ball rolling ball rolling.
Okay.
so we want to understand the
terms here the symbols here. What's what exactly
like what's this calculation?
and then
you know, we will have a thorough and foundational understanding
of
a neural networks